we have a legend in the house
or Mr egot I
was not a bad way to be introduced it
certainly is not when you're John Legend
I heard a story about your table at the
Vanity Fair Oscars party yes it was the
most sought after table to be at it was
a great table why well we had great
people there I sat with D Wade and
Gabrielle Union and Queen Latifah and
Kevin Bacon and Kyra Sedgwick and of
course my beautiful wife Chrissy was
with us and
at the table is like very entertaining
and very talented and very cool we
didn't know who we were sitting with and
we were like um Chris is like why don't
we bring an UNO card deck just in case
we like Uno kids like Uno everybody
likes Uno so we brought a stack of Uno
cards just in case the conversation you
know
just to get it going yeah but we
actually didn't need it but it was funny
as an icebreaker just to talk about the
fact that we had it there and I want to
congratulate you on your thank you
member of your beautiful thank you
that's SD I mean she doesn't play Uno
with us yet how are your how are her
siblings reacting they're doing so well
honestly I was a little worried
um because I feel like when she was
still inside Chrissy they were like a
bit jealous that Mom was bringing a new
baby into the world but once she came
out they were like they just snapped
into place they were like trying to be
really good big siblings they were
excited when she came home it just
brought more energy and joy really yeah
with Miles and Luna they're pretty good
they're competitive sometimes though
sometimes they compete over who's going
to be the best big sibling like who gets
to hold her more and and uh you know I I
love every aspect of raising babies it's
fun like I love the diaper changing I
love the tummy time and the learning
when they start seeing actual color
versus just black and white like how are
you and Chrissy with shared duties or I
change diapers too we both duties
[Applause]
we both we both change diapers I I even
did a campaign a few years ago with
pampers a daddy diaper Duty campaign and
I I would sing on behalf of all women
thank you thank you very much
it's the least we can do you know women
have to go through so much to bring life
into the world and breastfeed and all
these other things the least we could do
is change a diaper honestly
[Music]
I love you so much and I really mean it
on behalf of all women and moms thank
you and it's you know it is one of those
questions that's normally like reserved
also sometimes for women you know in
that way of like how do you do it all
how do you be a husband a father uh have
this profound career how how do you do
it well you have to find balance and I
think um you know it's sometimes it's
it's not always easy sometimes you work
kind of like has its own momentum and
you're like well I want to accomplish
this I want to accomplish that but then
you also need to make time for your
family and I really try to make time for
my family spend a lot of time with them
I uh drive my kids to school every
morning whenever I'm in town and I I
just want to make sure I'm present for a
lot of the milestones for them and so
I'm there
um but I do work a lot too I think it's
kind of like a negotiation with yourself
you're like well I'm and when you get a
little bit off balance then you got to
go shift to the other side yes and try
it and what is balance what is that
elusive person that thing people say
balance and it is very triggering for me
because it's like this concept that's a
little bit different for everybody but I
think another thing we have to allow
ourselves is
to figure out a way to not let guilt
overtake our mind
[Laughter]
[Applause]
especially as a parent there will always
be a reason you could feel guilty there
will always be more you could have done
more of this more of that and you can't
let guilt just kind of overtake you I
gotta tell you I hope you take this as a
compliment I'm really afraid you won't
but you speak like a woman
like you're
that means I'm wise well I
and I think I feel like it helps me
write music too it helps me write music
because I'm writing not only from my own
perspective but how it feels to be in a
partnership with someone and I think
seeing someone else's point of view and
having empathy helps you write songs
well you also have a family member the
same family member that I do okay a
bearded dragon
[Laughter]
we do have a bearded dragon Sebastian
mine's Jeremy
now the weird thing about bearded
dragons is it's hard to tell what sex
they are so we may have named a girl
bearded dragon Sebastian we don't know
we don't know what Jeremy is apparently
have you heard any tricks about how you
find out there is one
then you can see a prong that's a girl
or a nub that's a boy or another but I
gotta tell you it it doesn't feel that
distinct when you're trying to you know
so um I was wondering
um do you ever serenade Sebastian I've
I've never serenated Sebastian is there
any chance if I brought Jeremy out here
that you would serenade Jeremy sure
[Music]
foreign